have a shot my name's Sammy leaves I am
a property ambassador I make a lot of
money from investing in property and on
this video I am going to be answering
your property investment questions I'm
gonna do my best to answer as many of
them as possible what I want you to do
is I want you to comment your questions
below in the comment section and guess
what I'm gonna do next week I'm gonna
answer your questions next week so don't
forget to smash the like button turn on
the notification bow if you're not
subscribed do that now turn on the bow
and stop commenting your questions below
and that have silly might sound if it's
anything property violence will get you
tax related comment below I'll do my
best to answer so let's see what we had
from last week we had a guy called Lucas
Kirkham good day Samuel how do you think
the coronavirus will affect the market
do you think there'll be a lot of
distressed sales soon with deaths if it
is as bad as the fear mongerer are
acting this question keeps coming up how
do I think the coronavirus you can
affect the property market in the UK or
worldwide okay listen
the coronavirus is definitely having an
effect on people because people are
scared and whenever people are affected
by somebody keep both effects even
whether it be directly or indirectly on
a small scale a large guy is you know
affecting business it's gonna affect the
property market there has been an
article about this I think it was
written by the telegraph they said that
property prices were just beginning to
saw in the UK because of the borås
bounce and because when we left the EU
they would just begin to soar and they
think that the corona virus is making
people just a tiny bit apprehensive
right now so is he gonna affect the
property market it might a little bit
yes maybe we'll just slow the growth
that was beginning to happen I mean long
term I don't think that even well unless
we all die but hopefully that won't
happen I also think that the biggest way
it's the effect the market is serviced
accommodation because house prices I
can't say they're going to be massively
effective depends on what happens with
the coronavirus my guess is it the
coronavirus he's being talked about like
crazy the moment the news everyone's
talking about it
but it like lots of other things like
button mouth
swine flu these things usually come in
people talked about for a very long time
and once cared and then six months or a
year it kind of blows over and the world
goes on so I'm not expert in the corona
virus as a property investor I'm not
worried but I won't be surprised to
destroy he slows down the speed of
expansion and serviced accommodation the
tourist market I mean in the UK not at
the moment too much but that's probably
the one to watch so are we just keep it
on it and always look at worst-case
scenario and maybe I'll do another video
about it in a couple of months and I'll
see what's going on so great question
thank you so much for that question what
else do we have
Tom Hodges you say to be optimistic in
general came back from the previous
question yeah
but always look at the worst-case
scenario when deciding on a deal what
strategy or plan should we have with our
investment properties if there is a
recession or downturn in the property
market thanks love the channel and the
value give thank you so much Tom Tom
that's a great question so I do always
say to be you know positive in general
positive in life possibility yourself
but were you looking at a deal always
look at the best case and the worst case
and always put together a plan and
what's going to happen if the worst case
happens I mean even though that's the
kind of coronavirus or if there's a
recession in general and a recession
will usually happen because of three
reasons it'll be because the bank runs
out of money the people run out of money
or just fear generally just massively
are usually one of the above if you're
buying a property you need to say what's
gonna happen if the price drops now if
you're buying it to sell it and that's
the whole plan and it's not really a
particularly good rental property and
then there's a recession you're gonna be
really affected but if you're buying it
and your prize to just hold onto it and
rent it out and the rents really good
and the returns really good then you buy
it even if the value of the property
drops it actually does affect you at all
because you're holding on to it
ultimately do we know it's going to go
back up so that's what I'd look at I
just looked at watches strategy have an
exit strategy as well so if you're
planning on buying a property to then
sell it anything mean maybe there's
gonna be not much expansion then an exit
strategy could be to write it and what
happens if you rent it are you gonna
make Merlin is it going to at least
watch
space if it's not you're gonna lose
money on it and then you think they
potentially could be a recession there
maybe buying it to sell it is a bad plan
if that's the only strategy so I'd
always just look at exit strategies
sometimes exit strategies off exit
strategies best case worst case don't be
scared about the property price dropping
if that's not how you're intending to
make money shorts on anyway so I hope
that helps Tom answer your question
great question what else do you have
hi Samuel I wanted to know what the role
of the you Nestor is once the deal was
being carried out and I've secured a
property I couldn't see it you're
talking from you being a deal saucer or
a deal jack which I think you are the
role of the investor will the role of
the investors to buy the house so if you
if you've secured a property and then
you've passed it on to an investor
they're going to pay you their fee and
then they're going to buy the house
so that they're ultimately responsible
for making sure that the property is
something that fits their criteria so
they're gonna pay you your fee you're
gonna have terms of conditions which is
gonna protecting them and protecting you
they're going to do their due diligence
so I'm not quite sure if I misunderstood
the question with the role of the
investor is to invest the role of the
source owns the securing of the property
person are you in this case is to find a
good property and to match up the
investor with the property take your fee
and then you're gonna use that for you
probably to put together towards your
deposit on you listen topper tea as well
you want to be making money over here
investing money over here make make make
invest make make invest so you're gonna
be the source and the investor at some
point as well so I don't know if that
answers your question if it doesn't
maybe just drop another comment and tell
me that misunderstood it alexander PPG
hey Samuel my question I'm planning on
making friends and then making calls
like crazy to get deals to sell after
one or two deals to invest these money
myself let's exactly what you said also
you guys are getting this and the thing
is I don't have money to be compliant
with this can I just sell the deals for
less because I'm not compliant and with
this deal I will have myself be
compliant if it works thank you for
everything I can see myself successfully
because of you with all the knowledge of
yours I can do real estate investing
really easy for me love you man ooh
- so regardless of the fee that you're
charging if you're charging 500-pounder
if you're charging five thousand pounds
you really do need to be a compliant
deal sorcerer before you find deals and
package them and sell them to people and
the reason you want to be compliant is
because you need to protect yourself and
you also need to protect the investor if
you're not compliant and you've not got
proper terms and conditions you know
register with the property Ombudsman
then what could happen is you could take
money from someone even only a hundred
pounds and then down the line if the
property is really bad they can turn sue
you so you just want to make sure you're
compliant so what I would probably say
Alexander is if you haven't got the
money to become become compliant in what
I would suggest you do is you find
somebody if you're making lots of
friends which is awesome
so you find a friend or contact who is
compliant and then you find the property
and you say hey can you sell it for me
let them set it you found it and do it
do a profit share someone you sell the
deal for two thousand let them keep one
thousand because they're compliant they
found the investor you found the deal
and with that one thousand pound or
whatever it is if you make put that
towards becoming compliant so then you
can do yourself and your own investor
list
hope that helps love you too my friend
keep up the great work and keep watching
all right ridwan patel posting a great
channel when packaging a deal when
sourcing a lot of packaging deal
questions and when sourcing your
property how do you contact the actual
owner the Land Registry has names etc
but no contact details
eg the email address or phone number I
hope this makes sense thanks Reed wine
makes sense great question so if you
were buying a property and you're trying
to find a deal presumably you're going
to be looking for properties of people
that actually want to sell you know just
know you're just gonna walk down a
random street and go that would make a
great house I'm just not good on who
check that they're interested in selling
because you just can't even like a crazy
person like I was in America when I was
trying to find a house if you've not
seen the American video we'll leave a
link in the description below so you're
gonna be contacting sellers that want to
sell so who are these sellers that want
to sell well they might have their
property on the market in which case
it'll be on Rightmove it will be on
Zoopla
you'll be on estate agent shop-windows
that's easy you do pocket viewing and if
you want to speak to the owner direct
little trick is look reviewing in the
evening because the stage agents don't
usually like working in the evening and
that way you'll probably meet the only
direct or find them selling themselves
but off markings so look some signs
where they've got their phone when
they're selling themself or looking go
tree and spare room or open men who just
contact crazy lists even you know if
you're selling your house on Craigslist
or Gumtree you've got to be pretty
motivated so because they're selling
they can really point their contact
themself on these sites
you're gonna phone them up and say hey
you know what street what's your
motivation for selling what's gonna load
why should accept I already cashed my
get yourself a really good deal and then
package and sell it or buy it yourself
so I hope that helps great question and
good luck on your property journey what
else do we have
dr can hey Samuel thanks for another
great video thank you so welcome I have
secured three deals since attending your
crash course in January fantastic
congratulations three deals dude from
the crash course really and the crash
was by the way is a three two day
training program that I run and then I'm
gonna leave a description in the link
below do you want to come and spend a
couple days with me and learn about
property there'll be a link in the
description below
luckily the first of all got rented out
straight away back awesome being eager
to make a return on my investment I
think I know he's going back tunes I
drew up a quick contract and let the
tenant move in immediately only to
realize after that I probably should
have done some checks and got readings
on the boiler yeah but hey congrats that
you're just learning on the job but yet
for sure I did cover this a little bit
the crash course maybe at that point you
were just calling estate agents and
[ __ ] views look at me there were no
major issues good and it was a valuable
learning experience for me awesome to
save time and effort on my next projects
question what are your five pre move-in
checklist things to do before the tenant
moves in to avoid any complications or
problems in the future and maybe any
experiences of your own when you first
died as a landlord many thanks in fact
unfortunately next video thank you so
much I hope you see this deal calm if
you do drop another comment below so
okay
before
what I look for well firstly I would vet
attendant and you said five
I'll just missed a few neck subscribe so
get a work reference make sure they're
working get a credit check done on them
get a previous landlord reference and
when I say previous I don't mean current
is what a lot of people do that as the
current landlord hey they pretend
because I'm thinking of moving into my
house if they're terrible the current
landlord wants them gone for the current
landlord beside their amazing so you
want to go back to the previous landlord
who has never gender no axe to grind it
will tell you the truth and then also
just how much they're working from their
fours like an affordability check that
there are the basic things that you want
to get a let your agency in place really
important I mean you said yourself also
if you have to make sure you register
the deposit and you can do that one I
think it's okay
but again for my letting agents do this
for me and in terms of the actual
property
yeah there's think this things with you
I'm gonna need to make sure like you've
got a gas safety certificate the hot
water is working there are little niggly
things what you can do is you can
actually move in there for one night
yourself and living the property for a
day and see both then you'll very
quickly realize if there's any things
that you doing like you forgot to put
things up oysters that that's quite a
nice white so I hope it helps and
congratulations on your properties I
hope so ok what else do we have
dan barber okay we do this with you one
more I'm gonna wrap up Dan barber says
hi Samuel another amazing video thank
you your videos are getting better and
better each week thank you
my question is have you ever had
experience or notice possible to use
equity in someone else's property such
as karent's to invest in law property
yes and you know if you've got equity in
a house you can refinance okay no tax on
the money that you go out because is
debt you don't pay tax on debt but the
money that you get from the refinance
you can reinvest into property you can
take out more mortgages and put down
unity posits which
you a massive research on your cash on
your turn on so this can be done and if
you've got equity in a parent's house as
long as they're willing they are they're
gonna lend you the money
even as they hey look we financed you
might pay for three or four percent
interest to the bank give me the money
and I'll give you ten percent interest
get an agreement in place and then
invest the money and they can have a
charge on the properties that you've
invested or do it as a joint venture so
you're going to tell your parents so you
can attempt to refinance the house and
then with the money because you've got
the scale of time courage you're gonna
take that really you're gonna invest it
for them and you're gonna go 50/50 on
the profit so 100% that is possible good
luck with that
okay that's question frizzy about in Zed
Zed cool name I have a decent sum of
money saved and I'm ready to begin my
property journey however it is a two to
three hour journey to the place where I
were buying and do viewings my question
is this would it be small financially in
your opinion to spend some of my money
over forty thousand pounds on a car as
it would make life so much easier for
viewings etc I feel as though it's
necessary but I'm afraid to spend the
money are you saying that you've got 40
grand and you're thinking of buying a
car or you said you've got a sum of
money and you're thinking of investing
40 grand of the money into a car I mean
listen a car German speaking is a
liability because I can't goes down in
value and it doesn't give you any rent
however if you're using a car and you're
using that as a vehicle to get each of
properties that's going to making you
money then I guess you could argue that
it's an assets however just if you're
looking at this from a purely financial
point of view in a commercial decision
not an emotions or a luxury or I want
position 40 grand on the car is not
necessary at all you can buy a car that
gets you from A to B for five thousand
pounds easily so just think of it like
this if your property business and you
might not have any properties you want
to have any staff but if you have a
property business and you've got staff
and the staff needed to get from A to B
and do you some stuff would you buy them
cars would you bother 40 grand cars
probably not because it would be an over
expense so from a purely financial
business with their perspective why
would you spend for two thousand pound
on the car yourself if the reason is
purely business and finances
you could at least announced park for
two hundred and fifty three ninja pound
a month I mean you can lease range overs
for like five six and apparently so I
probably wouldn't buy a car I would
lease one but that's my general my
general feedback guys thank you for
watching this I hope you found those
answers useful but don't forget this is
your chance to have your questions
answered so comment below with anything
property related anything that's niggly
if any of these questions are answered
you have a proper suit of a question or
an offshoot to an offshoot just comment
it little below and next week I'm gonna
be taking some questions hopefully yours
you be my best hands number swim back
and seven in the air me thank you so
much for watching please don't forget to
smash the light zone subscribe and
listen if you don't turn the
notification bells on that's a problem
because I could be answering your
question and you don't even know air
lands a bit because you didn't see the
video pop-up because you give it to
another notification belt on so skip
subscribe turn the balance I'll see you
[Music]